bonsoir paul jorion merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france donald trump donc il
reste droit dans ses bottes il estime
que son discours de la semaine dernière
devant ses partisans avant l'assaut du
capitole était tout à fait convenable
peut-on le croire est ce que il ya du
vrai dans cette déclaration selon vous
son point de vue oui bien entendu il dit
s'être approprié c'est exactement ce
qu'on voulait et dit-il le peuple est en
colère le peuple est en colère parce que
il ya une procédure d le pitch
maintenant vers moi c'est la même chose
c'est toujours la la la la chasse aux
sorcières je suis la victime de la même
chasse aux sorcières qui a débuté il ya
cinq ans et il a il a fait demi tour une
fois de plus maintenant il
il se présente en victime et eux ils se
la manière dont il agit aujourd'hui en
allant sur le lan le rail qui devrait
séparer donc les états unis du mexique
en faisant une étape à alamo ou le
fameux ford à lamu où les ou de braves
américains des indiquant dit dentiste
texans se sont battus jusqu'au dernier
contre des mexicains
si y'a pas un symbole est là quelque
part non monsieur trappes n'a pas
l'intention de monsieur trump a
l'intention que le 21 janvier il soit
toujours président des états unis et il
agit à nouveau de dans cette logique
alors vous parlez de chasse on s'en sert
alors il est vrai que désormais le
président sortant est honni un bayonnais
d'ailleurs même par les réseaux sociaux
qui l'ont banni pour certains
définitivement est ce que c'est la bonne
stratégie pour les opposants à donald
trump qu'on les aime ou on n'aime pas
mais est ce que c'est le meilleur moyen
finalement de le faire taire que de
vouloir absolument
le bayonnais oui absolument
ce dimanche parce que bon un peu on peut
critiquer bien entendu le type de
démocratie qu'on a aux états unis c'est
un pays qui a commandé un bilan
extrêmement mitigés par rapport à sa
conduite envers d'autres peuples
mais les américains sont
voilà sont convaincus que leur type de
duprat ci mérite qu'on la défende
or là maintenant monsieur monsieur trump
a déclaré la guerre à ce type de
démocratie et donc tous les moyens sont
bons effectivement pour essayer de
contrer ce qui est une honte connaît
dans l'histoire on a déjà vu des choses
comme ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un coup
d'état fasciste
tous les moyens sont bons pour une
population de résister à une tentative
de ce type là parce que comme je le
disais il ya un instant il n'a pas
l'intention de partir le vin quand quand
il dit à monsieur baden qui sera pas là
lors de l'inauguration il faudrait le
fort c'est d'être là c'est un
encouragement encore à ce qu'on attaque
que la cérémonie de l'inauguration de
monsieur bynum site rome n'est pas là
s'il peut simplement envoyé ses troupes
pour essayer d'empêcher d'empêcher que
cette passation de pouvoirs et lieu
aujourd'hui qu'elle serait finalement la
sortie la plus honorable pour donald
trump mais aussi pour la démocratie
américaine
une démission une destitution une
transition ordonnée
quand va la promise donald trump
oui oui enfin il a promis sa non il
faudrait ses amis c'est qu'il lui reste
amis lui disent qu'il faut dire qu'il
démissionne
c'est le cas de monsieur kelly qui a été
son chef de cabinet le général kelly qui
a été son chef de cabinet pendant un
certain temps il parle plus à son à son
vice président monsieur me my penske il
a même demandé mardi dernier à la foule
compan de son vice président non il ne
le fera pas il ne démissionnera pas on
aurait espéré
je dirais les partisans de la démocratie
l'américaine aurait espéré que là je
dirai dans une dans une approche en
tenaille
d'un côté la destitution et de l'autre
côté le 25e amendement venant du côté de
la vice présidence c'était en criant
peut-être de l'éliminer mais là on ne
sait pas ce qui ce qui est très
dangereux bien entendu c'est que ses
partisans appellent à une insurrection
généralisée le 17 c'est dans quelques
jours
non seulement au niveau de washington
mais au niveau des capitals de chacun
des états c'est à dire bon ce qu'on
appellerait les préfectures en france
de la 50 endroits il y aurait eu une
tentative de ses partisans de rendre
pour j'ouvre les guillemets de rendre le
pays à sa population qu'on annule le ces
fausses élections selon eux qui ont eu
lieu dont le processus qui est en cours
bien entendu c'est la passation de
monsieur baden ayant gagné de manière
légitime des élections dont il ya deux
visions absolument inconciliables et
elles vont déboucher le manière la plus
probable
on aura quelque chose d'une 1 sur 2 2
lors d'une insurrection généralisée ce
qu'on appelle en général une guerre
civile soit le 17 soit le bain merci
bien nous suivrons ça évidemment avec
attention ici aussi sur arte france
merci à vous pas le genre liant d'avoir
été avec nous en direct